plus de réflexions sur qui vous pourriez
épouser d'accord je ne le ferai plus j'ai
eu deux mariages cela a juste coûté
beaucoup d'argent au studio pour les casser
bien nous devions avoir ceux qu'un ancien était
à une figure mineure de la mafia Vince était  pas
mineur et Buddy Flynn était un chef
d'orchestre avec une longue histoire d'usage de stupéfiants ouais
ouais c'est ce que je dis qu'ils étaient
tous les deux des lunettes épousant un troisième Lausanne
ne me fera pas de bien si nous faisons des
clichés très appropriés de jeune homme propre joli garçon et  swish ce que tu penses s'il
n'y avait pas un bon homme fiable
je ne l'attraperais pas qu'en est-il de Cecily
est le père n'est-il pas ouais
le mariage ne doit pas durer
éternellement mais à la fin d'avoir un enfant
sans un  le père présenterait un
problème de relations publiques pour le studio les
images aquatiques nous vont très bien
dites que vous allez attacher un poisson et
Mariana dit seule que les images vont bien
pour nous tous et c'est un hommage à vous
le public vous aime parce qu'ils  sais à
quel point tu es innocent c'est Joe  laisse-moi voir
si Owen est ouvert au mariage ouais tu es
sûr qu'il est le père absolument est le
père oui presque sûr dis ta ligne
exactement comme je suis sur le point de le faire juste comme je suis
sur le point de le faire
bien sûr si c'était si simple
Oh quoi  nous a-t-il fait la même chose serait-
ce que c'était si simple serait-ce la
même chose  que c'était la
même chose qu'est-ce que ça aurait été un échantillon
qui était ma bouche avec le Detroit
n'est pas ce que c'était la même chose garder la
tête immobile avec un système de torsion serait
-ce que c'était tellement enregistrez-le sur Twitter eh bien
je suis  essayer de dire que m.  Durant's
lorentz hmm j'ai pensé il y a une minute que
c'était Lorraine ouais nous pouvons utiliser Christian
sait que mon bien a bien fait mon Lawrence
tout comme je t'appelle heureux d'accord alors qu'est-ce que
c'était que c'était un son qui trébuchait serait
le divers un truc simple que tu ne dis pas
trébucher tu dis le lion trébucher
je te préviens ou la courtoisie avant de
lancer l'histoire de demain c'est Lee ouais je
viens de voir ton je ne me soucie pas de comment tu fais
quelle est l'histoire c'est il n'y a absolument
aucune vérité que je ne stocke pas je me crois
Oh  vieux rassis aujourd'hui
ce qui m'a un peu dit qu'ils ne sont pas
apparus sur le plateau aujourd'hui
oh que non non oui il a dû faire une
pause
blessure mineure salut
Spray eh bien pensiez-vous que je voulais dire non
rien j'ai vu que votre sœur
essayait le plus tôt  ressusciter quelques vieux potins
à ce sujet oh je suis sûr qu'elle était ce
canapé, elle ne connaîtrait pas une nouvelle histoire si
elle la mordait sur le postérieur ouais eh bien,
elle est une entorse à la cheville haute est-ce vraiment
le meilleur que vous puissiez trouver que
nous connaissons tous  le coureur de jupons et la
boisson  Jags et les voyages à San
Berdoo là c'est un bon père de famille il
a une entorse de la cheville haute mr.  Mannix,
quoi de neuf,
cacahuète ?  la rue le cinéma
oh ici c'est la soeur Alicia les
chercheurs pour enfants du rang suivant dans le pré New York
prennent un distributeur et mélangent des cas pour
faire ça cardiaque à la seconde Oh si si si
on t'apprend à informer et paladinous
ta allumeuse voit socialement un  petit mini un
visa pour que vous soyez une
groupie un nouveau-né dans les quads qui
peuvent être déplacés vers dr.  akido creuser dans
la zone commune est l'activation de la
stellosphère illusoire regarder Roanoke l'homme a
développé un film avasculaire sur le côté
il pourrait vous faire vous voir
dans une gamme d'équipements du samedi pour le
gothique savoir mais n'est-ce pas cher est-ce
Joan à
peine puis arrêtez Mahalo